hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book one of his work of stoic ethics
on duty cicero distinguished four main
sources of the good of the right of duty
of what it is that we ought to do these
are the cardinal virtues wisdom justice
temperance and the one we're going to
discuss here courage now Cicero is going
to use several different terms he will
refer to it as fortitude oh the word
that we get fortitude from and he's
going to discuss what with genuine
courage consistent and how we can
distinguish it from from other things
that look like courage but are not
actually courage but he also uses the
language of great-souled miss he talks
about you know an animus a mind that is
is raised high and he says that this
actually has like the other virtues its
origin in human nature so the stoic idea
of living in accordance with nature
means following out certain very
fundamental basic inclinations that are
implanted within all of us as human
beings he talks about this in Chapter
four he says that nature gives us as he
calls it a desire a hunger is how it's
translated here for independence and not
just independence in the sense of being
financially independent or people not
telling you what to do but self-rule the
Latin for it is Prynne capataz for
rulership not necessarily rulership over
others but certainly over oneself so he
says that we have a hungering for
independence so that a mind
well molded by nature of course this
does not include everybody is unwilling
to be subject to anybody save for one
who gives rules of conduct or as a
teacher of truth or who for the general
good rules according to justice and law
and he says from this attitude from this
this way of thinking out of this comes
greatness of soul magnitude Oh enemy
and a sense of superiority to worldly
conditions so Cicero is saying that
within all of us
according to the Stoics there is this
basic fundamental drive or desire for a
kind of independence a kind of being
able to set our own goals being able to
pursue things even against resistance so
that's really key he says that this
leads us this is in Chapter five to
greatness and and nobility of soul and
this is in fact he calls the greatness
and strength of a noble and invincible
spirit this is one of the four sources
of the good and then jumping much
further into his his more specific
discussion of it in chapter 18 he's
going to add a little bit to this he
tells us that there are a number of
different duties right and he says we
must realize we've set down four
cardinal virtues from which as sources
moral rectitude and moral duty emanate
then he says that achievement is most
glorious in the eyes of the world so
this is recognized by by culture and
including our own culture which is one
with a spirit a mind an attitude great
exalted and superior to the vicissitudes
of earthly life again we have this this
sense of Independence courage involves
being able to rise above the things that
would ordinarily drag the animal you
know down or other human beings who have
been then you might say deprived of this
this drive through one way or another so
he's using this as a prime example and
he says that you know we we attribute
compliments to people by talking about
the brave and noble work of their great
soul so he says you know think about and
he was bringing a battlefield courage
marathon Selima Splott heya Thermopylae
right and then he says think about our
own coke lace the decade
these are people who are heroes to the
Romans ghanaians and Publius skippy oh
and we might think in our own time about
people who we consider to be brave or
courageous or to have a great soul those
who rise above and you know we may not
be able to relate to these earlier
examples but we can find many of our own
so that's sort of the staging now what
are the Stoics themselves actually have
to say about courage itself well he
brings up the stoic definition of
courage in chapter 19 and this is in the
course of telling us what courage is and
what courage is not giving us a caution
about how we need to think about courage
if we're going to understand it rightly
because we might be getting the wrong
cues from our own culture from those
people who surround us they may tell us
that something is courage when it's not
really courage so what are the Stoics
have to say about it he tells us that
the Stoics give a definition of courage
as the virtue that fights for the side
of right so courage itself is a kind of
rightness but it only remains rightness
when it fights for the side not only of
itself but of something more than itself
rightness is not encapsulated completely
encouraged it has to be connected to
other forms of rightness so he says yeah
here we go
fortitudo is the the virtue which he
says prople Nanta that is taking the
side getting in there and fighting for i
quita thing what what is actually just
so what is courage going to do like we
have here courage must defend or promote
the common good this is a really
interesting statement here it cannot be
concerned merely with its own selfish
gain now that may raise some problems
people because you could say well if I'm
defending myself against a bully or if I
am you know taking a risk in starting a
business or something like that maybe I
guess I'm not courageous according to
the Stoics well think about think about
the bullying example if you're actually
defending yourself against some sort of
aggressor
what are you preserving are you only
preserving yourself or are you
preserving a person who actually by
other ways serves the common good are
you preserving as Epictetus might say
the person of fidelity the person who
can be trusted this is the bully can't
but you perhaps can and in doing so you
are in fact preserving the common good
because you are part of that common good
now if you were only doing it because
you like to get revenge on bullies you
become some sort of vigilante well that
would not be courage according to Stoics
or according to to Cicero who agrees
with them on that so you know he says no
one has attained a true glory who's
gained a reputation for courage by
treachery and cunning for example
nothing that lacks justice can be
morally right one courage or what looks
like courage is being used for purely
selfish ends he says it actually
transforms from being a virtue and turns
into a vice the opposite of virtue the
things that the Stoics considered
intrinsically bad for human beings and
many people who think themselves
courageous probably are caught in this
very situation so he says if the
exultation of spirit seen in times of
danger and toil is devoid of justice and
fights for selfish ends it's a vice it
has no element of virtue its nature is
barbarous and revolting to our finer
feelings so he says that we have some
criteria here the people who are
genuinely courageous he says need to
actually be good Bono's some
straightforward simply case
to be lovers of truth he also adds to be
enemies to deception but I think that
goes along with lovers of truth and he
says these are at the center of justice
so you can see that justice plays a very
important role in Courage he also adds
that that those who prevent injury are
to be considered brave and courageous
not those who do injury so those who
have a natural aggressiveness those who
are prone to attack others that doesn't
make you courageous what makes you
courageous is when that impulse is used
for the common good he adds as well that
that genuine courage consists primarily
in doing things not in Fame not in what
other people see but what it is that you
actually do a little bit later in
chapter 20 he tells us that the soul
that is courageous and great is marked
above all by two key characteristics one
of these we've already talked about to
some degree says its indifference to act
outward circumstances such a person
cherishes the conviction that nothing
but moral goodness and propriety
deserves to be either admired or wished
for or striven after and this person
also desires that they not be subject to
any person or passion or accident of
fortune so again courage means a sort of
independence from other people but also
of the the drives and desires within
ourselves it's not courageous for
somebody like Cicero to fly into a rage
and to go and attack the enemy because
that's to be captured by one's own
passion what else is involved here in
courage he says the second
characteristic is that when the soul is
disciplined in the way above mentioned
one should do deeds not only great
in the highest-degree useful but also
extremely arduous and laborious and
fraught with danger both to life and to
many up things that make life worth
living
so courage at its its peak you might say
is going to be by its very nature
engaged with the sorts of things that
that do tend to make people feel fear or
desire or anger or other things the
things that present resistance to us the
things that require us to invest of
ourselves not only our own time and
effort but perhaps even our own bodies
and our safety and to put it at risk
again it's going to be for some sort of
common good so this is what the Stoics
consider courage to consist in you can
see that it's quite different in some
respects from what many in our own
culture would consider courage whether
it's the hyper aggressive 'ti that that
some people value or the you know taking
a moral stand when it's easy to take a
moral stand that really wouldn't be
courage either according to the stocks
there's something very different that
lies in the middle and that is going to
be fulfilling all of these
characteristics and criteria now this is
a very important virtue because without
courage the other virtues are going to
be difficult to see through because
courage deals with things in times of
adversity and that is what we are going
to run into sooner or later
you